同学们好啊，咱们又上课了。
昨儿刚录的课，今天接着录。
最近有时间嘛，就多录一点啊。
这节课讲啥呢？这节课讲的内容呢，很多同学其实已经点播很久了啊。
讲单元句。
讲一下单元句。
单然剧算是一个比较大的门类啊，比较大的门类，它有自己的特点。
所以呢很值得讲一讲。
当然了，通过一节课的时间未必能讲得很透彻，咱就尝试着跟大家探讨探讨啊。
这个。
其实从上节课开始啊。
上节课讲这个人为什么要看电影？
从这个角度。
其实呢我们就是在。
灌输一种新的学习逻辑和学习理念。啥理念呢？就是我们以后啊不管学。
学到啥？
知识学到啥门类，不光是影视啊，你学别的知识也是啊。
我们必须有一个基本的思维，就是。
遵循原理，扬长避短。
啥叫遵循原理？扬长避短呢？
追循原理就是你得知道这个东西它是怎么来的，它为什么会存在？
对吧他是什么道理？
你得从原理上了解它。
然后呢，一个东西你了解了它的原理之后，你就会知道它的长处和短处。因为所有的东西都有长处和短处。
你就可以。
发挥它的长处，弥补它的短处。
就是坐在长处上去填那个短处。
所有的东西其实都是这样？上节课讲影视剧，我们说。
人为什么爱看影视剧？我们先得了解这个原理，对吧？影视剧是一个艺术啊，我们就先讲讲艺术是个啥。
人为啥需要艺术？
对吧猫啊狗了咋不需要艺术呢？人为什么需要艺术？这个东西吃饱了撑的需要个艺术。
我们得先搞清楚。
然后呢，影视剧它是艺术中的一个门类，比较新的一个门。
而且呢比较全面。我昨耳也说了，它里面包含了其他艺术。
有文学在里面，有音乐在里面，有画面在里面，对吧？甚至有剪辑艺术在里。
它是一个新的艺术形式，我们就可以推导出。
人为什么爱看影视剧？为什么需要这个东西？
然后我们再从审美的角度讲了人去审美艺术的时候，他内心的内心真实的内需，内在需求到底是什么？
然后你了解了这些原理之后。
你看你在写你的影视作品的时候，你就知道原理是什么咋回事，你也知道影视这个艺术。
相对于其他艺术，他一定也是有它的优点和缺点。
我们不能说我们自己是搞影视的啊，影视牛逼，影视全面，影视表现形式丰富，所以呢肯定就比小说强比漫画强。
那可就不见得，小说漫画活的好好的对吧？活的好好的。虽然你。
看起来比他全面，但他活的好好的，为什么呢？就是因为你有你的长处，也有你的短处，他有他的长处，也有他的短处，谁也灭不了谁，对吧？影视作品里面有那么多插曲主题曲、片尾曲，你也干不掉流行音乐嘛，对不对？
各有长短。所以说。
八个字的学习逻辑。
遵循原理，扬长避短，这就是我们从上一节课开始给大家灌输的一个东西。所以这节课讲。
单元句我们同样是用这个逻辑去思考。
就是。
先遵循原理，就是单人剧它是个什么东西。
他为什么会存在？
对吧它的特点是什么？然后找到它的特点以后呢。
扬长避短。
两两必短对吧？单元剧不同于电影，不同于其他的连续剧，那它一定有自己的特点。
我们就从这个思路去学习这节课，好吧。
啊，插一句啊。
我因为很三个月没上课了吧，是吧？
我因为三个月没上课了啊，所以这个这个。
在在准备今天上课之前呢，我昨天把前面我上过的课少了一点，因为我早期上课啊，不瞒同学们说啊上的有点随心所欲，确实。
讲了些什么，我其实自己也不太记得了，因为很多课也没有备课。
讲了些啥呀，不太记得。
我就往前扫了扫，看了看，我都讲了些啥。
别出现讲那个自我矛盾的地方是吧？原让人看出破件破绽，那咋整？
然后呢往前一看啊，我就顺便看了看弹幕。
我以前没有看弹幕的习惯啊，毕竟我到这个岁数了，弹幕对于我来说是个新兴的东西。
我们做影视当然知道有弹幕啊，但是一般影视剧啊，主流平台影视剧的那些弹幕啊都是假的，会花钱买的，都是那个机器人。
或者是花花雇雇那种水军打的。
但是咱们这个课因为不是个商业产品，所以这个弹幕。
呃，应该都是真实的。但是弹幕这么多有点出乎我的意料啊。
然后我就看了看弹幕。
其中有一些弹幕啊。
看的让我心里。
有点。
这个这个这个心里一慌，我想今天借这个机会跟大家说一下啊，因为我经常在课前扯淡。
说很多生活里面的事儿与知识无关的事儿。所以有弹幕说哇，这个老师真好，不但教我们学习，还教我们做人。
哇，我一听这个话，我感觉有点严重啊。
首先在这里我要强调一下。
查理老师只教三样东西，第一就是知识。第二，学习方法。第三。
学习理念。
绝不教做人。
好吗？我没有绕任何教做人的意思，也没有任何教做人的意图。
因为你们作为年轻人啊。
教你们做人的人太多了。
而且你们记住一句话。
凡是教你们做好人的。
都是坏人。
他们把你训练成好人，他们自己当坏人欺负你。
明白这个道理吧。
不信你们回忆一下。
你们的爸妈什不时候教你们做不好？
你们的爸妈是最爱你的人。
但是你回忆一下，你离开家去上大学的那一天，或者你离开家去大城市打拼的那一天，他咋跟你说的？
他一定跟你说，出门在外要长点眼啊，对吧？不能轻易相信别人。
是吧关键时刻要尖一点儿，别吃了亏。
这是你正常的爸妈跟你说的话，没有一个爸妈把女儿送出去的时候，在外面一定要做个好人啊，一定要相信别人，一定要乐于助人，吃点亏不要紧。
呵呵。
你爸妈会教你做好人吗？不会的。
好吧。
所以。
你爸妈都不教你做好人。
查老师也不会教你们做好。
当然我也不会教你们做坏人，跟我没有关系，因为我也不是一那么会做人的人。
我就教知识，好吧，所以以后不要聊这个。
看得我头皮发麻。
我操这不误人子弟了嘛，对吧？教知识还有自信，教做人，这个不可以啊，以后别聊这个事儿了啊。
咱赶紧上课，免得又让大家觉得在教作着。
单元句啊。
咱们是新黑板新教室啊，大家应该看出来了。这个这个这个因为咱有教室了啊，而且现场有学生。
大家鼓个掌，让大家然后大听一听。好好，ok ok。
六七个人鼓出了千军万马的感觉呢，你们可以，差不多就行了。
单元据啊。
刚才说的八字。
遵循原理。
扬长避短。
那我们就先研究一下啥叫单元句，对吧？研究一下这个概。
跟以前一样，概念这个东西啊。
听明白就可以了，不需要有绝对的这个这个这个。
绝对的范本。
单元句就是啥呢？单元句就是一集一个故事那种剧。
简单理解啊，就是一集一个故事那种剧。
独立。
因为啥呢？因为电影啊往往是单机独立的。
G往往不是单据独立。
用。
课本上的那种词儿的话叫。
电影是闭合型剧情。
啊电视剧叫非闭合情剧情。
这是课本上的词。
往往不太好理解，对吧？因为绕闭合不闭合，你还得想他妈为什么叫闭合，你就想他这么就独立的。
你知道吧？
电影的故事是独立的。
因为他得。
怎么起了头，怎么结了尾，他得对观众负责，他得完事儿，对吧？让你满足感有头有尾完事儿了。
对吧这一下完事了。
电视剧呢它一集一集是连续的。
所以呢它是非闭合型的，它是开放型的。
然后嘞。
是连续剧。
单元句呢。
就是。
单集故事独立。
但是呢你说哎他为什么又叫聚的？
大部分单元句啊，它还是有东西要连续的，对不对？还是有东西要连续的。我们之前课场好像也提过它场景连续，人物连续，对吧？人物关系连续，人物成长连续。
那他还是有一些东西的延续的。
所以我们可以理解为它是一个。
半闭合型的或者叫半开放型的一个剧情结构吧。
单集的剧情是独立的，但实际上还是有东西在连续的，对吧？剧情肯定是要独立了，否则就不成为单元。
这就是单元句的一个定义。
一个定义。
咱也不考好吧，你理解了就行了。
那单元剧是咋来的呢？
单元句啊其实就是。
电视剧。
蓬勃发展的那几年，我们说电视剧早期啊大家一定要注意啊，早期啊早期电视剧它是就是爆米花剧嘛，或者叫肥皂剧，它是电视广告的马仔，对吧？催眠大家看电视广告了。
所以呢那时候这个这个电视剧刚出来的时候，一个东西刚出来的时候肯定蓬勃发展。在蓬勃发展的过程中呢。
就是大家找到了一种。
新的电视剧形式就是单元剧，它有个什么样的优势呢？它就是可复制性强。
适应那个需要批量生产的年代。
所以呢这个门类应运而生了，在蓬勃发展，在电视机蓬勃发展的那几年。
单元剧出来了。
当然他也不能说是完全无根之水，就是那几年出来的。我也说过，早年的中国古代很多早年的小说。
其实就是张辉体。
我们说影视剧是拥抱了文学的。
先进技术嘛，对吧？影像技术拥抱了文学，变成了影视剧。
那你去拥抱张回体。
那你显然就搞出来就是单元句嘛，对不对？济公传它不就是单元句吗？
这个这个这个西游记九九八十一难，它不就是单元剧嘛，对吧？
所以说这个单元句啊。
它产生是有根据，有土壤。
然后呢，我们说那这个东西。
他这几年发展是什么样的呢？
他这几年的发展啊。
目前在这个。
主流的平台上。
单元句基本上固定为三个门类了。
基本上形成了三个门类。
就还存在三个门类的单元句，比较主流。
第一种。
儿童类。
以动画片为主啊，以动画片为主。
儿童动画片吧。
儿童动画。
第二类呢，我们说叫。
单演喜剧。
单元喜剧。
就是以搞笑为目标的那些剧，单元喜剧单元喜剧里面。
包含一个子集，一个重要的力量，叫情景喜剧。
的全年喜剧。
然后第三个门类。
我们统一的称它为任务类吧。
任务类单言句或者叫探案类。
暗暗嘞。
因为它主要的形式是卡。
我们好理解啊，探案类全部是单元句，一级破一个案。
一帮警察或者一个派出所，一个警察署。
对吧怎么。
每每剧出一个N多个系列，什么芝加哥警署、迈休斯敦警署、迈阿密警署对吧？那个那个夏威夷警署。
就是以探案为主。但其实你可以理解为它是任务类，因为不光探案。
还有那么解决。
民间小事，比如说呃律师的。
对吧律蒸类。
还有抓鬼的吗？对不对？康斯坦丁他么一级抓一个鬼。
所以我们可以理解为它叫任务类。
任务类就是你明确的知道这个剧他是一级要干一个某种类型的任务。
我们这么去理解啊。
但这名字都是瞎起的，你理解就行了，好吧。
基本上现在固定为这三个门类。
儿童动画类。
单元喜剧以及探案类任务类。
儿童动画类啊全部都是单元句。
全部都是单元句，为什么？
待会再说。
我们接着说。
我们说我们了解了一个东西的原理以后啊，我们基本上就可以理出它的特点。
或者叫优缺点，因为我们要扬长避短呀。
扬长避短呀。
我们说来。
既然有。
这有电视剧，那有电影。我们说还要有一个独立的门类，叫单元剧的话，那单元句的优点是什么？
优点。
显而易见可以想到的啊。
第一。
就不写了吧，要写好多字。第一，单级比较完整啊。
单辑比较完整，是不是啊？就是你单辑看一个东西有头有尾的。
看着哎呀得到了内心的满足。那一集你看到东西了呀。
不像看连续剧，有时候这一集没讲什么事儿，对吧？而且终于要有个结果的时候，哎，请看下集。
有时候你心里就不爽这件事情对吧？
心里不爽这件事。
所以他你看他的第一个优点就是单级完整。
然后第二个优点是啥呢？
第二个优点啊是故事种类丰富。
因为你每一集都可以起一个新故事，所以你的故事种类是比较丰富的。
你可以某一集去。
去搞个鬼屋吧，某一集去他妈冒险，来个金羊毛。
某一集爱情。
对不对？某一级愚者成功。
都可以。
都可以故事种类比较丰富，束缚比较少。从创作的角度来讲，束缚比较少。
然后第三个优点是什么呢？
灵活调整。
因为单元句啊往往就是。
级数比较多，对吧？这起步不整个七八十级啊。
对吧干个三年四年的，一年来个二三十集。
啥叫灵活调整呢？就一看观众不喜欢看哪种类型。
不喜欢哪个演员。
就给他弄掉。
啊哈，换了他。
对对换了他。
这个这个写新角色，对吧？
就是。
可调整。
灵活可调整的空间大，因为每一集都单独来嘛。
但是这个呢其实啊更适用于海外的创作环境。
咱们国内呢。
就这个优点啊可以单独给大家。
摊开来讲一讲啊，就是关于这个灵活调整这个事啊。
咱们国内的调整啊只能以季为单位或者以年为单位。因为咱们的审查是这样啊，就是你全部拍完之后。
剪好了送去审，你才能知道你这个玩意儿吧，它有没有。
出生证有没有资格去上？
所以呢你不可能说哎。
拍着拍着发现哎这个剧情不好，我们改一改，那个是在咱们国内是不太现实的。
不太现实的。
咱们的审查一般一般来说分三次。
第一次呢是你先有这个。
项目的。
想法的时候，你先写1个1500字的梗概，加1个300字的思想内涵。
1500字的梗概呢基本上就是什么人发生了一个什么事儿，经历了一个什么样的过程，最后呢得到了一个什么样的结果，一般是这么一个简单梗概，不管是电影还是电视剧啊，都得写。
然后呢，300字思想内涵呢就是这个这个我们的主角是一个什么样的人，在这个过程中他领会到了什么？然后通过发生的这些事情呢，我们又向观众传达了什么。
弘扬了什么样的？
正确的价值就这是个思想内涵，这是第一次。
给这么个玩意儿。
第二次呢一般来说啊稍微重点一点的项目，主流一点的项目呢要省一次全本。
就是你全部剧本写完了以后，还得让人再看一遍，看看里面有没有不合规的地方。然后呢，人家再告诉你一次。
然后再下一次就是全部拍完了之后，把文学文本的东西变成了画面的东西以后，成了成品了，还需要再送去人家再看一遍，看看里面有没有不妥的地方。
经过一般是经过这么三次，然后拿到出生证才能跟观众见面。
所以呢这个灵活调整这个事儿啊。
在这几年啊，在国内的这个这个单元剧当中啊，或者在国内所有的剧当中啊是实现不了的。因为你不管你是怎么整，你还是要全部拍完。
就送下。
但是前些年是可以的。
前些年是可以的。
比如说我爱我家。
啊，，你们记得那个剧吧，对吧？那个剧呢就是一个标准的情景喜剧。单元喜剧里面的一种情景喜剧。啥叫情景喜剧啊？情景喜剧它就是搭一个舞台，现场有观众，然后嘞像一个话剧舞台一样，现场有几个机位，然后有一个导播边拍。
编那啥，然后就就直接就就剪出来了，相当于看话剧。
这么说吧，相当于我今天这个情况，我正在上课，然后直接又露出来了。
这这就是一场情喜剧，对吧？这是一场情情喜剧。早年咱们国内也有这种形式，也有这种形式，它其实就是标准的情景喜剧。
在那几年为什么可以的？因为那那几年啊这个这个东西他送审不是按影视剧送。
他是按电视栏目送的。
所以当时是电视台自审。
相当于他就是说这叫栏目剧。
栏目剧。
就可以。
不去送审，省掉那个环节。这样的话他就可以哎周播或者周双播，然后随时换演员，随时调整剧情。
这是那个年代特有的一个。
短暂的一个福利吧，就那么几年是在什么什么之后结束了呢？
我不知道同学们里面有没有四川的啊。
四川电视史上曾经出了一个很牛逼的片子。
在我年轻的时候，在我小时候吧，那个片子非常火啊，收视率相当高。
叫红蜘蛛。
后来出什么续集，叫什么红问号，反正红什么什么。
他专门讲什么啊？专门讲女性犯罪。
专门讲女性犯罪。
就是一个风尘女子，因为结交了一个什么什么人，被人骗了多少多少钱，最后向那个男人痛下杀手，切下了他的什么什么。
这种剧情它就很强烈，观众看着就很过瘾，明白我意思吧？
这种谁不爱看啊，每一篇都是活脱脱的故事会啊。
故事会级别的尺度啊。
然后呢。
他用一种伪纪录片的拍摄方式找一些群众演员，找一些完全不会演戏的人去。
还原这些事儿。
观众看的相当的诡。
然后呢，因为你很难在卫视上看到这么大尺度的东西。
那他是怎么过审的呢？他就走栏目剧。
他不说自己是剧，他说自己是栏目，他加一个什么包装呢？就每一集开始之前有一个人拿着个话筒走进画面。
观众朋友们。
在四川的达州发生了一件耸人亲瘟的故事。有一个女孩竟然写下了她男朋友的。
接下来我们就看看到底发生了什么。
然后就开始进戏了，就加这么几十秒的一个东西，然后就骗。
也不叫骗广电嘛，就反正就人家自称自己是个栏目。
不是个剧。
然后就因为非常火，所以每个电视台争相模仿。
觉得我操。
这么玩啊。
加一个主持人在前面介绍一下，对吧？
各位亲爱的观众朋友，我们来看一下这一集曾小贤跟胡亦菲到底发生了什么。
你就不用审了，你就不用送审了吗？
然后各电视台争相模仿。
然后就把这个因为这个东西吧，我跟你说，这个这就像什么啊，一个地方，如果有有黄金，就你自己知道啊，你天天去摸一点是挺开心的。但如果全村的人都知道了，村长肯定马上下令不许抠了，这个地方的金子不许不许挖了，对吧？所以这个。
栏目剧就。
就没得了。
就没了。
所以现在的这个所有的剧啊，刚才是岔出去了啊，就是讲中国曾经有过情景喜剧。
好吧，但现在没了，后面你们在看的那些看起来长得很像情景喜剧的那些东西。
其实都不是倾京戏剧。
他不是边拍边播的，他也不是一个。
他的话话剧舞台、旋转舞。
不是，就是正常的摄影棚搞成那种形式。
去拍。
甚至有的还加上罐头笑声。
因为原本情景喜剧的那个笑声。
实际上就是现场观众发出来的声音。
因为他是直播嘛。
但是后面中国拍的那些类情景喜剧。
是因为要走那个模式，但是我们达不到那个条件，我们制作播出的这个流程达不到那个条件。所以呢我们就就就就模拟一下。
模拟一下。
这个大家了解啊。
就刚才是说到这个。
单元句的优点。第三个优点就是灵活，肯定相对还是灵活的。
好吧。
灵火。
然后那基于这些优点，他还有第四个优点，就是观看的时候啊，观众是比较舒适的。
比较舒适的。
这也是一个优点。
为啥？
因为你在上帝视角。
咱们这么说吧。
单元喜剧啊。
或者是大部分的单元句，你其实啊。
是不入戏的。
其实是不入戏的。
待会儿我讲为什么。
就你不需要入戏。
不要入戏。
相对舒适。
但是我们说啊。
所有的事情都是两面的。
都是两面的。
缺点也同样非常的明确。
第一个缺点大家都知道，我曾经也说过，没有黏度呀。
没有年度呀，看了上集，看不看下集都可以，对不对？
没有事儿牵挂，没有年度，对吧？当然这与剧情独立与你观看舒适，没有入戏都有关系。
对吧你缺乏黏度。
然后。
第一个缺点，我们说缺乏黏度。
第二个缺点呢。
第二个缺点呢，故事模式啊故事模式。
容易单一。
故事模式容易单一。因为你看啊你这几个人。
比如说啊比如说你是一个单元喜剧，你这几个人在这几间房间里天天闹闹哄哄的。
谁能惹事儿，谁能平事儿，谁跟谁吵架，谁欺负谁，谁暗恋谁。
基本上。
观众都有数。
所以单级故事模式是容易出现。
单一的情况了有可能会重出现重复，你必须要知道这个缺点，我们才能待会儿才能扬长避短。好吧，知道这是个短处啊。
单机模式容易单一。
第三个缺点就是故事规模。
只不事规模的问题。
故事规模偏小啊，因为篇幅有限。
天幅有限。
你一即要把这个事儿结束掉，所以你的故事规模啊是偏小的。
这个确定我们要心里有数。
但是不要慌，都是有办法解决的。记住我说的话。
守住你的长处，弥补你的短处，你就赢了。
做任何事情都是这样呀。
对吧做任何事情都是这样呀，打拳不也是吗？守住你的弱侧，对吧？发挥你的后手权。
都是一样的道理。
写东西也是这样的道理。
守住你的优点。
挨个弥补你的缺点，你知道你自己的故事规模小。
有办法解决。
第四个缺点第四个缺点。
就是啥。
单元剧的人物啊。
一般来说啊没有什么大的人物弧线。
没有什么成长。
没有什么人物弧线，没有什么成长啊，有个什么显性的劣势呢？就是显得你在这个故事。
不那么有内涵。
明白这个意思吧？
就显得很肤浅。
人都没有成长。
对吧没有学到一些什么东西，没有精力。
巨大的。
内心对抗，所以显得。
不那么有内涵。
这也是为什么？
除了情景喜剧刚出来的那几年。
以外。
后面的情景喜剧基本上很难出现高的评分了。
你爱看，但是很难给他高分。
啊，就像那个那个那个麦当劳一样，你爱吃。
但是呢你很难说麦当劳真是美味啊，你们都不好意思说。
对吧？不好意思说，你如果觉得麦当劳很美味，显得你没有内涵。
对吧。
这是第三第四个缺点，内涵差点意思。
他的意思。
确实没有内涵，对吧？
没有内涵或者是表象上。
这就是我们说的。
单元句。
还有明确的优点和缺点。
我们说来。
这就是我们这节课的第一部分。
但学许记他到底是个啥？
咋来的？
他的优点和缺点是个啥？
我们说基于这些，我们才能写好它。
才能找到好的方法去写它。
才能去扬长避者。
那为什么？
那为什么我们这节课要讲一下这个单元句呢？
因为啊。
我认为啊。
单元句。
越来越适应现代的时代。
越来越适应现在的时代。
你看啊。
单据的优缺点，我们刚才各说了4个，但是优点我没写。
确定要把它写下来了，为啥呢？我就想让你看一看。
没有什么黏度，黏度比较低，对吧？然后呢，情节比较单一。
你这这。
模式化对吧先怎样再怎样模式化，对吧？黏度低，模式单一，然后呢规模比较小。
对吧这个规模比较小，然后呢，也没有什么内涵。
这四个特点。
你不觉得眼熟吗？
这四个特点是个啥呢？
这四点加在一块，不就是你们天天花两三个小时刷的那个玩意儿吗？
不就是你们天天沉迷于的那个短视频吗？
对不对？他不就无限趋近于。
你们喜欢的那种单一模式的爽感。
我们说短视频为什么能火起来？
他就是捕捉每一个人的爽感，然后给你单一的刺激。
就像我每天都会刷到大长腿，我也不知道为什么。
但是我还都看完了。
导致他又不停的给我推。
单一是吧？模式单一，每个我跟你说连背景音乐都一样。
那些发腿的那些女的，我不知道他们从哪逃换的音乐，反正每个人的音乐都一模一样。
然后运镜也一模一样。
先是一个屁股，然后慢慢拉开往前走，我一直等他回头，但是他也不回头反。
就是模式都一样。
绝对没有内涵。
真的没有什么内涵。
而且我前面也说了啊。
单元句啊。
有一个重要的门类，就是儿童动画。
我刚才说。
这个我们先放着，待会儿再说。
你说儿童为什么喜欢看这种东西？
他记不住你粘他什么呀。
你知道吗？儿童记不住上一集喜羊羊跟灰太狼到什么程度了？
所以他每一集打点打料。
第二下一集喜羊羊跟灰太狼又重新打起来。
上级的仇都忘了。
为啥？因为儿童他记不住呀。
明白吧？年度。然后我们说规模这个剧情单一也没有问题，他就要看单一的呀。
奥特曼打怪兽每一集剧情都差不多。
他就是要那个单一的。
单一的剧情啊。
单一的剧情就还他还爽。
明白吧？
我们说规模比较小。
没有问题啊。
没问题啊，我是儿童呀，我脑子里面能记多少东西啊，跟我小。
你跟我小孩子谈什么内涵？
儿童呀。
对吧。
所以我说儿童动画一水的。
代愿句。
一水的纯纯的单元句。
纯纯的单元句，而且基本上是纯闭合。
人物也没有变化，喜羊羊跟灰太狼第一集长什么性格？第300集还是什么性格？
纯闭合。
儿童动画适合于儿童。
但是。
互联网的发展。
啊我们大家，我们这些新的一代人，年轻人已经训练的。
越来越像儿童了。
我们都是baby。
我们现在就是baby，就是巨英。
所以我觉得啊。
中小体量的。
单人句。
会迎来他的。
爆发了。
会迎来它巨大的市场的。
这就是为什么这节课想把这个。
拿出来跟大家讲一讲，好吧。
对。
试着从里面学点东西。
来儿童动画我们抛开不说，我们这一课讲一下。
单演喜剧和任务类探案类。
我们说第一种。
单元的喜剧。
其中包括。
情景喜剧啊包括情景喜剧。
这种单元句我们其实看的挺多的。
国内你像什么。
这个早期的家有儿女呀呃编辑部的故事呀啊编辑部的故事有点复合类型啊。我强调一下啊，一个单元喜剧它同时可以包含任务。
任务也可以任务类的喜剧，也可以是单人喜剧。
动画也可以是动画的单元词句，明白这个道理吧？它互相是不是严格分开的啊，就像我说的故事类型一样，有很多剧它是跨跨类型的。
编辑部的故事其实编辑部的故事其实就是情景喜剧，单元喜剧加探案。
明白吧？编辑部的故事它是个单言喜剧的模式，但是他每一集呢他要都要跑出去惹事。
都要跑去做任务，因为他是个编辑部嘛，对吧？
但是像什么家有儿女呀、武林外传呀、爱情公寓呀，它就是标准的单元喜剧，甚至可以称之为情节喜剧。
那这种剧我们说它有个什么样的特点啊？
我们还是从单元的角度去理解啊，首先它单元肯定是闭合的，单元完整。然后嘞，那它什么连续了？
行情连续是我们最先想到的。
情景喜剧的场景是肯定是连续的。
对吧我们说我们先就来看场景啊，情景喜剧，情景喜剧剧嘛，它有个场景连续的问题。情景喜剧的场景一般来说就是5到8个之间，5到8个之间啊。
不会不太会超过10个，一般就是一个。
1个3千米的棚就解决了，30千0平米的棚就解决了。
一般会搭一个什么呢？
有哪几个场景啊？
第一，需要有一个共同出现的场所。
这个是所有情节喜句需要解决的问题。因为你你的角色啊有很多，对吧？待会我们说的角色问题啊，我们先就说场景一个情节喜剧，它的场景啊需要有一个共同出现的场所，这也是为什么情节喜剧的第一组场景往往是一个。
咖啡厅。
酒吧。
客栈。
或者是办公室，就这些人如果恰好所有的主角，如果恰好在同一个工作场所的话，那就用办公室。
那就用办公室。
或者像炊事班的故事，那就是那个食堂。
对吧就是那个餐厅嘛，他们就全部坐在那。
或者是那个什么。
东北一家人。
反店。
对吧饭店。
有一个共同出现的场所。
然后呢。
再就是主要。
主要角色的卧室或者叫家。
因为这个地方需要承载承载很多爱情戏。
状态系。
对吧？
然后呢，其他人也可以过来串门。
然后再就是办公地点。
如果刚才那个共同场景不是办公地点的话，再就会出现个办公地点。
基本上就这三类场景三类场景。因为办公地点和卧和家。
一般不止一个，所以综合起来构成一个5个到8个之间的一个。
所谓的。
场景。
这也就是情人喜剧里面需要连续的东西。
连续这个场。
我们前面说为什么需要。
有一些共同出现的。
这么一个场景呢，为什么这么需要这个场景呢？因为单元喜剧啊，它的人物设定也是有讲究的。
单元喜剧的人物一般来说，主要人物大于4。
小于6。
主要人物啊，我们说是身上经常扛主线的人物。
一般来说小于6个。
为什么啊？
是因为。
在美国研究的啊，因为美国做这种剧做的时间比较长，比我们长，他们已经研究出一些现成的经验供我们借鉴。
是因为他们认为一个观众同时能记住的角色。
不太会超过6个。
所以一般的情景喜剧不鼓励角色。
超过6个。
有没有超过6个的？当然有当然有，但是呢不鼓励这么做。一般来说极限是6个。
但为什么又说。
不不推荐小于4个。
是因为啊。
在喜剧里面。
因为。
场景有限。
故事规模也有限。
故事模式也有限。
所以一般来说啊。
采用。
多谢叙事。
就这边在干嘛，那边在干嘛，这边在干嘛，那边在干。
去干点嘛的时候呢。
一般不能一个人去。
你路上都有人聊天啊。
得有人跟你沟通啊。
你不沟通，怎么能让观众知道你们两个来干嘛，前因后果是什么，害怕什么，想要什么，对吧？
所以你看啊，如果双线去势一条线俩人，这不就四个起步吗？
就是这不就四个题目嘛？所以啊一般来说啊是这么一个设定。
这么一个设定。
你看这就是一个单元喜剧，不管你要不要做情景喜剧。
如果要做情侣喜剧，你的场景也需要你设计。但如果是你是一个单纯的单言喜剧，场景呢就不需要那么太去在乎了。因为场景也可以按照传统电视剧就是有一组场景，但是也有广广泛的外景，也可以嗯呃我哪穿，对吧？爱上哪上哪去。
人物呢一般是主要人物啊，扛主线的人物，扛事儿的人物一般是4到6个，或者我们叫常驻角色。在这个里面的常驻角色。
这就是从人物的角度，从场景的角度，你先要有一个基本的设定。
这是人物角度，这是常景角度。
然后我们说但愿喜剧啊但愿喜剧它是个喜剧。
他还有一个非常重要的。
东西需要你去设定叫人物关系。
叫人物关系。
我们说啊人物关系实际上是单元喜剧中连续的最重要的东西。
就是他连续个什么玩意儿呢？你说连续个场景，连续的场景，其实我们观众是没有酌情点。
是没有酌情点。
没有着力点。
但是你如果连续的人物关系，观众还是能够一定程度共情的。
我们说过啊。
所有的单元句，它的缺陷是什么来着？是观众在上帝视角，他其实不那么共情。
明白吧？当然你也可以说这是优点。
观众不那么关心。
這些人物。
这你可以说这是个优点。
对吧你也可以说这是个缺点。所以我说为什么要扬长避短？
观众不怎么关心，观众不共情。我们这么说吧，观众不尽戏。
优点是什么？就是观众没那么紧张。
相对舒适。
罗伯特麦基。
在他的教材里面说过。
这个喜剧啊。
喜剧就是避免观众共情。
因为观众一旦共情，他就不希望了。
对不对？你一旦觉得卓哔雷好可怜啊，我跟卓便拎是一样的人，那你就笑不出来了。
那你就笑不出来了。
对吧。
不共情啊。
你看我们随便举个例子啊。
曾小贤在戏中。
歹徒挡着他一把菜刀砍过来。
你还在笑。
你明白这个意思吧？
你喜不喜欢曾小平？你其实蛮喜欢他的，但是这把菜刀砍下来的时候，你丝毫不会觉得他一他你完全不担心他会受伤。
明白这个道理吧。
你不担心曾小贤会受伤。
因为你有绝对的安全。
你对剧情有绝对的把握，绝对的安全。你看透了。
哎呀呀呀。
胡飞马上来救他。
对吧你看透了。
你安全这是优点。
对吧这是优点。
但是任何一个优点都有另外一面缺点，就是你我有时候还是想让你动点。
那个了嘛？
所以说那着力点着力在哪？
人物关系。
一把刀砍上曾小贤的时候。
你笑。
你一点儿不担心他受伤。
但是他跟胡一菲吵架的时候，你哭了。
因为人物关系还是可以用来着力的这就是我说的扬长立短。
所以要设置人物关系。同时单元喜剧里面人物关系实际上是剧情的永动机。
这个道理大家心里要有数啊，它实际上就是剧情的永动机啊。
你就是围了这事儿来做了，咱就这么说吧。咱今天因为都是编剧，咱可以明着说单演喜剧里面，你的剧情啊，你其实就是从这个这这个反复的人物关系拉锯里面。
去去去构建的。
那我们就来。
研究一下这个人物关系。
大是喜剧里面好用的人物关系，我们大家一起想一想都有些啥。
都是学生。
最好用的啊，第一种必然竞争。
那种双男主、双女主或者是强男一女一碰到一块了，就他俩一直在竞争。
一直在。
当然竞争也有也分种类啊。
有的就是压制型的。
就是一个老能压制，另外一个观众看这个爽感。
对吧永远看爽感，偶尔翻一次，观众很开心的。
偶尔那个弱者往上翻一次啊，观众很开心的，但是你放心，下一集马上又把它打下去了。
为啥？
人物关系连续，但年喜剧里面人物关系不要搞给我搞变化。
懂吗？不要搞变化，不要搞颠覆，谁强谁弱摁死了，他偶尔当然可以反一下，但反完了之后再打下去。
因为观众要这个爽感。
儿童就要需要。
有一集光头强熊大熊二，我操。
人物关系一下反反转过来，小朋友接受不了的。我跟你说。
给他摁回去，好吧，这是一种竞争关系。还有一种竞争关系啊，也有势均力敌的那种也有。
就是两个人势均力敌，那你就可以做什么？做此起彼触。
就这集他占优势，下一集他占优势，这局他在占优势，这集他在占优势。然后这一集呢他好像要占优势了，但是他让了他一下。
他让完他之后，他没有觉得他让他他觉得反而觉得自己牛逼，然后他就生气了，下一集我往死里整。
你看这就是此起彼伏，看起来模式单一，但是也在里面寻求变化，还是扬长避短的思路。好吧，也在里面寻求变化。你看竞争关系。
还有什么关系啊？
还有追求关系。
对吧谁一直追谁，这个也非常常见。
我们说的追求关系同时可以衍生出三角关系。
对不对？
我们说在单元喜剧里面经也经常有三角关系。
然后再就是那个那个反转关系。
也是经常用的。
经常用的在单元喜剧里面，比如说什么美剧里面有很多什么什么废柴舅舅呀什么。
呃，什么什么小姨啊，什么什么。
就是本来应该是一个他照顾他。
但是是一个反转关系，结果是那个小孩照顾这个。
这个不成气儿的。
舅舅或者小姨那种反常关系也是经常用的。
我们说在这个单元喜剧里面，人物关系是剧情的永动机是非常重要的对吧？就什么那个克制关系，对吧？谁是谁的天敌，对吧？报复关系，谁是谁的仇家。
对吧然后再。
这种大家可以多去找一些啊。
每个同学可以多去找一些补充到补充到你的素材库里面，我一下也想不出来太多。但是最常用的呢实际上啊还是在人物设定的时候，直接就出现的叫trouble make。
对吧。
那个那个那个咱们应该叫什么呢？用汉语说的话。
呃，就是反正就是惹事儿的那个人，对吧？惹事儿的那个。
和平事的那个。
惹事儿的和平事儿的那个。
当然啊当然啊因为是群系嘛因为是群系嘛。
所以惹平事儿的往往有好几个。
惹事的可以只有一个啊。
平事的往往有好几个。
当然这个是最常用的啊。
然后还有这些啊，当然可以复合啊可以复合型的。比如说他跟他是个竞争关系，他跟谁还有个三角关系。
这是可以可以复合好吧，关系是可以复合。
当然了，我们再说回去啊，那为什么有这么多人？
为什么有这么多人？
我们说情年喜剧，为什么说？
搞出这么多人物关系，这么多人呢。
人少点不行吗？
因为我们说单言喜剧观众不共情，不入戏啊，他站在上帝视角，你知道吧？
他不是跟着某个人走的，他站在上帝视角，他站在上帝视角啊，人往上帝视角一站，我跟你说就就拽起来。
人一旦拽起来之后啊，他喜欢谁不喜欢谁啊，他会很明确。所以你给他你得给他多几个选择。
而且他还愿意安排CP。
明白这个道理吧？所以你看啊传统的情节喜剧，因为情节喜剧。
跟。
当然喜剧啊情情许绪跟任务类探案类的剧有个重大的区别，就是这种剧情啊一般比较轻松，而且里面要伴随着浓重的爱情。
因为轻松的剧情，你要是再没有爱情，那就清汤寡水了。
所以它一般伴随着浓重的爱情元素。
所以在常在常规的单元喜剧里面。
这个人啊。
往往还都不够数。
啊，就是是什么有单调的。
就男女永远不平衡，你别搞三男三女啊，三男三女那就太平衡了。
一般还搞出故意不平衡。
让。
观众有这种组CP的那种。
哎呀，这个积木拼不出来了，你知道吧？这也是一这个这个有些教材上的一种提法，就是让观众产生组CP的时候产生困扰。
你看这就是。
单元喜剧你从设定层面，你需要考虑的一些问题。
你的场景，你的人物。
你的人物关系。
你的人物在剧情推动中起到的作用。
就是这些。
我们说那。
这些都设定完了，那我一级一级整吧。
一级一写啥呢？
在教材上啊用的词儿，我觉得翻的不太好。
翻程叫。
情境。
每一集遇到情境，但它的原文叫situation。
对吧。
其实就是遭遇吧，situation。
那其实你就可以参考。
参考之前我提过了什么乔治perie说的什么36种situation，比如说。
复仇。
比如说求告对吧？比如说奸情。
对吧比如说。
机遇。
什么误会呀。
冒险呀。
竞争呀对吧？博弈呀，这些都是标准的situation。
那些东西啊可以给你一些启发。当然啊是基于你的设定啊。
比如说你这一季要出去冒险。
每一个千年喜剧，每一个单元喜剧在每一季里都会出去冒险一次，自己回去看。
都会出去冒险一次，走出他们的小房子，出去冒险一次。你去看什国大爆炸，你去看任何一个都会跑去。
为什么会出去冒险？
这是一种又一种新的剧情形式，但是依然跳脱不开你之前设定好的人物关系，你的永动机制，你的谁谁是谁去去冒险的时候，惹事的那个还惹事儿，明白吗？平事儿的还平事儿。
所以就是这就是。
情景喜剧或者叫单元喜剧的一般构建思路。
一般构建思路。
你捏好这些。
结构上就不会出问题了。
那洗不洗得起来，这个就要看你了，对吧？这就要看你本事了，或者我看我们后面再慢慢训练嘛，这个就不是一堂课能解决的了。所以如何能够更好笑啊，这个就不是一节课能解决的。我先把这个原理告诉大家，好吧，这就是单元句。
呃，单元喜剧。
或呃其中包含情力喜剧，就是这么一个基本的。
构建思路。那我们来总结一下来。
我们说缺点是啥？哎，这缺点怎么被我擦了？
咱们背背啊，缺点是粘度低。
这个这个这个模式容易单一。
然后呢，这个这个蓄事规模小。
然后似乎没有什么内涵，对吧？这四个缺点，我们说优点我们已经都发挥了，通过这些设定已经都发挥了。那缺点我们怎么去弥补呢？
年度低怎么去弥补呢？我们说啊。
基本上用人物关系去言。
基本上用人物关系几年啊，一般来说。
就要有一对人的感情比较复杂。
比如说啊最简单常用的就是谁追求谁。
爱而不得，对吧？或者对他的爱没有表白，或者两个人我爱他，他也爱我，观众能看到你爱他他也爱你。但是呢两个人没有表达，没有表达呢就让观众很着急。
或者是呢我来到这个地方呢，实际上是想杀了他。
因为我认为他杀了我父亲。
但实际上观众从观哎你们要一定要记住啊，观众在上帝视角。
什么叫上帝视角？
洞悉一切啊。
明白吧？
不要瞒着观众啊。
单元喜剧里面理论上给观众的信息越多，观众的爽感越强。
所以我刚才说的这一切都是观众知道的。
我来到这里，实际上是想找你报仇。
我杀你。
然后假装你的同事室友现在跟你生活在一起，伺机杀了你。因为我认为你杀了我父亲，但实际上呢。
你并没有杀我的父亲，你反而是我父亲的朋友。
这一切观众都知。
都知道。
不要瞒着观众啊，在担任喜剧动员，信息都给观众。
你看这是不是也可以增加年度呢？
它其实也是人物关系的一种。
好吧。
也是人融关系的一种。然后来剧情模式比较单一，又是一种。
怎么呃也也是也是一个劣势，我们怎么解决呢？
就是我们的situation啊要经常换，懂吧？不要老是去遇到一种情情况的事情。
事情有多种多样呢？你要发挥它去是灵活的优势。
就是因为他可以遇到各种各样的事情，你不要总是基于肖eldon的缺点，肖don的缺陷总是让他吃一样一样，在一样的问题上一样吃鳖。
懂吗？不要进么去重复。
我们说。
确实规模比较小的问这个劣势怎么规避呢？那我们就是把连续的东西给它加强。
也就是我经常说的那个单元句里面的暗线，把那条暗线做强。
暗线做强，对吧？如果是条感情线，把那条感情线做强。
一定程度上增强叙事规模。
那么。
第四个缺点就是显得那么没有内涵。
这个问题怎么去规避呢？
这个问题我们就不管。
没有内涵，对吧？你说没有内涵就没有内涵了。
好看不就可以了吗？对不对？
单元喜剧。
我们说第二个门类。
看案类的任务类的。
我们也来研究一下。
我们说任务类啊。
他也是单元句。
他有很多任务类的剧啊，人家也带喜剧元素，但是他为什么不归在单言喜剧的？
类型里面。
那这个类型他有什么自己的特点？
他就是这个任务。
就是这群人干什么？
这件事儿。
是比较明确的。
而且也是我看这个剧的。
呃，根本目的。比如说我点开一个芝加哥警署。
我肯定不是为了去看副警长跟。
那个法法医之间的爱情。
明白吧？
他俩也可能有爱情，但那绝对不是我要看的东西。
绝对不是我要看的东西。
我要看的。
是这个任务。
很明确。
所以主角团队的行动目标。
是非常明确的，而且是吸引观众。
观看此类片子的最根本的。
实习医生格雷对吧？每集都是。
好，实习医生格类是连续的。
呃，就是那个那个什么急诊室的故事，对吧？梅一集强调一个人，警警察类的、律证类的、抓鬼类的对吧？我看的是你的行动目标，我看的是你破案。
这个才是我最要看的东西。
我最后看这个了。
所以说这一类的片子它有明确的受众，明确的目标。
你这就这这这群主角假设就是探案片，你这群主角每一季都给我探案。
你按要是看不明白。
你这两个人的爱情做的再凄美。
他跟他之间再有仇，他跟他之间再是竞争关系、追求关系、三角关系都没有用。
我主要是看那个。
所以说这是这类行动类的片子，它最大的特点就是它有个明确的行动目标。
你是要破案还是要打官司，还是要他们救治病救人？
必须非常明确。
好吧，这是这种类型的片子。
那么这种类型的片子，我们说它先天的我们的主角团队，我们的主角团队。
主角一般也是团队啊，因为我们说这个不管是什么单元句，不管是什么单元句，都符合这个啊，都是4到6这么一个设定啊，都是4到6这么一个设定。那他显然是一个团队，他必须有一个共同的行动目标。我们说共同的一个行动员。
对吧那这就符合我们之前给大家讲过的主角团队一旦有一个共同的行动员的话，那么每个人的私事儿。
资自的那个事儿。
需要与行动员。
将继。
只要与主线人物相抵触。
比如说在。
探岸之余。
我想谈个恋爱。
请你放心。
这个女朋友后面一定要犯事。
他要么是。
犯罪嫌疑人要么是受害者。
你去看。
主角团队。
的人只要有私事儿。
一定要与我们的主行动员。
讲抵数。
降低处，这就是。
这类片子。
的一个特点。
然后主角团队的设定当然也符合这个4到6，好吧。
那么跟这个喜剧有个什么样重大的区别呢？
主角团队因为有一个非常明确的行动目标，那么主角团队的人物设定就不是这样的了。
就不是这样的喜剧人物设定了。
主角人物团队的设定更像超级英雄。
更像超级英雄。
也就是说，每个人要有比较明确的技能和缺陷。
比较明确的技能和曲线。
但是这个技能和缺陷是咋设定呢？
不要瞎设的。
明白吧？比如说你设定我的这个。
警察的缺陷是结巴。
这个缺陷就不是那么狠缺陷，他只要开枪牛逼，接巴不接吧无所谓。但是如果是个律正系，它是个结吧，那这个设定是有效的。
也就是啥意思呢？这个技能和缺陷是需要与主行动目标主行动员有关的，否则就是无效设定。
明白吧？
因为。
任务类的单元句一切服务于我们的这个主行动目标。所以我们主角团队的技能和缺陷必须。
技能能帮助到这个行动目标。
缺陷能耽误这个行动目标。
假设你的行动目标是探案，那每个人需要有探案不同的技能。
以及如果自己有缺陷的话。
缺陷是要影响他按的。
这就是这类片子，另外一个不同于其他片子的特点。
还有。
这类片子还有一个重要的特点，就是任务类的。
片子还有一个重要的特点，就是这类片子啊。
没有实际意义上。
比如说我们看探案片。
每集的那个案子要是足够精彩。
实际主角是那个杀人犯。
你说人为什么爱看犯罪的片子？
你们明白这个道理吗？
为什么罪暗片是全球。
影片里面的第一大题材。
我上节课说过影视是个梦。
影视是个梦啊。
影视作品是人类共同的梦了。
所以电影电视剧是描绘人类的梦的呀。
所以是我。
明白吗？
犯罪是每一个人的梦。
没人拦着你们的话，你们都想犯罪。
懂吗？
我们可能现在被我们受的教育。
被道德给压制住了。
但如果他不压我们。
犯罪是个梦。
这也为这也是为什么红蜘蛛红问号当年能那么火呢，是吧？为什么那么火呢？
上节各位说过呀，性和暴力。
电影的根基。
犯罪是个梦啊。
那谁在犯罪啊？
罪犯在犯罪呀。
罪犯啊从实际意义上来说啊，其实是这类片子的主角。
你哪怕你这个案，哪怕你这个所谓的主角团队里面是福尔摩斯跟华生的。
你给他们来设定再多的花里胡哨的人物关系，花里胡哨的。
人物技能花里胡哨的那种爱恨情仇。
主角啊我们看什么呢？还是。
每一级的犯罪。
这也是为什么你们去看西方的最案题材片。
我不敢说10个有9个吧，10个有8个。
第一集。
是连环检查案。
为啥呢？
因为这是你能想到的最可怕的犯罪了，连环杀人的话都没有连环，因为他又奸又傻。
对吧又奸又傻。
连环奸杀人。
那么滑稽少女。
女孩嘛？我不是说女人最能引起女性最能引起呃女性受害引起大家的共情嘛，对吧？老妈老婆女儿嘛。
所以。
在这类题材当中，我们需要知道爽感是什么呢？爽感就是每一集的案子要大。
看出殡不怕事儿大。
每一集的案子要大要狠。
我们的这些人呢其实就是一双一双眼睛。
线索。
带着大家去经历这个过程。
带大家去经历这个过程。当然了，我们为了尽量还是我说的那句话啊，扬长避短啊，我们必须保住这个优势。
优势是啥来着？
就是这类片子。
因为也具备单言剧的所有的特征，就是单极灵活。这个啊你故事丰富，你去去找案子吧。
你能找到最好的那种案子，你就往里安吧，观众就要看。
观众最想看的就是那个你得把这个保住。
洋茶。
然后B端是什么呢？
这类片子啊观众。
不看主角了。
对吧完全不看了完全不看了也不行啊，完全不看了，那不是看新闻了嘛？
对吧。
你的主角再去加强，加强主角的人物关系，人物动机、人物弧线。
加强主角的这个这个这个参与感，这就是我为什么刚才说的。
主角如果有私事的话，一定要与主线目标犯冲啊。
明白吗？你这个。
连环奸杀案的这个凶手，你去看这类片子。
最后肯定要奸到我们警察局某一位同志的家人身上。
明白吧？
这就是把那个。
把我们的这群看似像旁观者的主角硬生生的。
拽回来。
弊短，扬长避短的弊短。
他们也给带进去。
然后如果是律政戏打官司那种戏。
最后肯定要打自己的案子呀。
对吧肯定自己家里人也陷进去了呀。
然后让观众既看了案子，看了爽感，然后又替我们的主角担心了一把，硬生生的把观众给拽过来。这就是这类片子的常用技巧，也是在扬长避短，明白这个道理吧？这类片子啊必须担心喜剧啊，他是。
允许我们做一定的。
人物关系变化和人物关系成长。
明白这个意思吧？因为我们不是需要靠，因为我们不需要靠人物关系去驱动。
喜剧结构了。
不需要靠人物关系去驱动了。我们靠的是大要案是吧？案子带劲来驱动。
来驱动剧情。所以说这类片子啊半闭合的更多，剧情半闭合的更多，你人物可以有成长，可以有变化，对吧？可以有成长有变化，人物关系可以有变化，人物可以有弧线。
所以呢在这类片子中，你甚至都可以买一条那种。
颠覆性的大阴谋大暗线。我不是说过吗？增加单元句的。
年度最好的方法就是埋暗线嘛，大家喜剧里面往往买点爱情，这个里面完全就可以买点复仇啊。
买一种对人物关系产生重大颠覆的那种反转的那种大限。
完全可以埋啊，不用不用不用担心，是可以做的。
这节课呢就是通过。
我们上节课这个这个给大家介绍的这种思路。
学习每一样每一个单品的时候啊。
我们要了解它的原理，遵循这个原理进行扬长避短。
讲一讲单元句，算是概述一下吧，一节课也不可能完全讲明白。
大家从里面学点东西。
如果还需要有补充的，我们以后继续探讨。好吧，咱们细水长流。
下节课见，拜拜。
嗯。